donc vous savez ce que vous saviez
sûrement là qu'il était très dangereux
déjà l'écho qu'ils étaient capables de
passer à l'acte puisque vous savez bien
que à l'époque soviétique condamné sur
mulhouse
quand il était incarcéré là bas pour
avoir mimé les actes terroristes qui
s'était passé au bataclan et on savait
très bien qu'ils étaient capables de
passer à l'acte puisque des écrits
professionnels désigner clairement
l'individu et disait précisé qu'il était
très dangereux pour le personnel
pénitentiaire qu'est ce qui aurait dû
être celle déjà première question
d'ailleurs qu'on pose aujourd'hui est ce
que l'administration à l'époque a
transmis déjà c'est ces documents au
parquet et si c'est le cas pourquoi il
n'a t-il pas été poursuivi pour ces
faits deuxième point
malheureusement les collègues
aujourd'hui compter g en meublé scénario
ça n'aurait jamais dû arriver
ce détenu à réguler se retrouver dans un
quartier étanche pour des tenues
radicaliser avec des mesures de
précaution très très sécurisé pour les
personnels c'est-à-dire des mouvements
très limité stricte menotté à chaque
déplacement
c'est un cas exceptionnel
malheureusement il ya deux profils
aujourd'hui s'il n'y a pas un changement
politique radical
malheureusement de mars doivent se
retrouver encore des situations même
peut être plus dramatique donc
aujourd'hui on demande on exige que tous
ces profils de détenus ailier des
quartiers spécifiques avec une gestion
spécifique
nous avons affaire à des faux voilà et
il faut que personne protégée des
personnels pénitentiaires ce que je dis
protéger aujourd'hui on aucune
protection
ce détenu aurait comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure
avoir des mouvements très limitée des
visites très limité très encadrée
fouillés menottés et les personnels
équipés